[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 135 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I Mach Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work Melanie how are
you doing today I'm good how are you
mark I'm doing well great what's
happening today I feel like I have a
very deep voice today divorce
okay so mark yeah tell me about this
week yeah this week we're gonna chat
with Emmy Martinez who is the technical
lead for a company called virustotal
virustotal
is a company that does a lot of really
interesting stuff in the security space
we like security well as always before
we get into the interview we will start
off with our cool things of the week and
we will end with the question of the
week and this week's question we have a
special guest who's going to help answer
a question that we got from one of our
listeners yep the question being that
what is the best practice for
multi-tenancy
in google cloud spanner especially if
customers are not of the same size and
have unequal load and that's coming from
Andrew Sheridan so yeah yeah we'll have
rubber Kubus a little bit later
all right cool things of the week so one
of the cool things is that basically
this last month they've added a new data
type new data import formats and finder
cost controls and so the new data type
is numeric and the data formats are for
ingest our Park a and O are C so that's
basically available as a natively
supported format for ingest into
bigquery and then Lex said there'll be
some more finer cost controls and that's
all in the log posts that we will
include in the show notes another cool
thing of the week is that dataflow
stream processing now supports Python
which is a great thing to be supporting
because frankly the Python is such
important language in the data space so
now you can use that with dataflow data
flow stream I should say my pythons
terrible like just really bad but yeah
that's fine everyone will be very easy
for you if you ever want to approach it
I've tried a couple of times
mark realizes that his approach has
enraged the Python and to be safe
he must retreat with oh you do yeah it's
a manciple stuff in python what were you
doing wrong anyways one other cool thing
of the week is that we're announcing a
new certification for google cloud
certified the associate cloud engineer
yes and this is in combination with some
of the other certifications that we have
out there like professional cloud
architect it came out in 2016 and also
data engineer so this is just another
way to further expand and become an
expert in the space yeah so if you're
interested in an associate cloud
engineer is someone that deploys
applications monitors operations and
manages enterprise solutions there yeah
so if that's something that you think
that you fit into this certification may
well be for you last cool thing in the
week that we wanted to mention is
relation to next which many of you have
heard us talk about before is coming up
later this month oh my god I better get
some stuff done yeah yeah so there's a
blog post that's out that emphasizes
some of the AI and machine learning
talks that are gonna be going on that
people should check out some of them
being like the how to get started
injecting AI into your applications
architecting live NCAA predictions from
archives to insights this is something
we mentioned in cool things a couple
months back Eric Schmidt one of our
colleagues was working on this we also
have another colleague Martin corner who
has been doing this whole series around
tensorflow deep learning and modern
convolutional neural nets without a PhD
so all of these things will be at next
yeah it's actually worth noting if you
haven't been back to the next website
for a while there's actual times for all
the sessions so you can actually go in
and see what everything is doing all the
tracks and everything that's going on so
there is a lot of content that's great
yeah so definitely go check it out if
you're registered if you have your
tickets go in sign up make sure you have
a bit of an idea I think I think it's
gonna take some planning there is really
a lot of content that sounds fun awesome
well why don't we go chat with our
friend Amy over at virustotal and talk
about all the security things sounds
good let's do that so we have a really
interesting project today Amy Martinez
is here virus total tech lead to talk to
us about virus total today Amy how're
you today
I'm the
in great thank you thank you so much for
coming to join us virustotal is super
interesting but before we sort of start
talking about that do you want to tell
us about a little about you and what you
do here at Google okay so I'm actually
tech lead for vice total and that's no
more that I'm a software engineer that
gets to work with legal with marketing
and sales etcetera I happen to actually
put strapped these sales at VT at the
time because after acquisition we didn't
have any sales personnel and before that
we didn't have either so basically I was
wearing the engineering hat in the
mornings and in the afternoons how it
was doing sales so what it means is I
have a broad visibility of the product
and I can answer many questions
excellent well okay so at a high level
what is virus turtle yeah so so most
people think that by your total is
simply public facing website to which
you can upload a file and get fever
addicts from more than 70 antivirus
solutions in order to get a second
opinion about the maliciousness of a
file and that's like the basic
understanding for the novel users if
you're a bit more curious you probably
have discovered that we not only scan
files but also euros domains IP
addresses and the bottom line is that
we're receiving about two million files
a day and we're doing tons of URLs and
scanning and the main type ease so
eventually what happens is we're not
only running IVs on files we are also
running all sorts of tools that extract
metadata and relationships about files
and the other items that we scan so for
instance when you upload a file and it
happens to be an executable we will run
it in a virtualized environment and
we'll get to see what that files does
when it infects a machine we will then
run all sorts of micro services that for
instance if you upload an executable
file to virustotal
it will try to a sip file to virustotal
any compressed bundle I will try to
decompress it and if there's any
interesting files within that bundle
re-upload two values total and get the
inner files scan so we do tons of micro
services on the files URLs and the rest
of items that we scan and eventually
what happens with all this data is it
gets into our data
which this thesis over 2 billion files
and the end product of all this work is
we get to create the service which I
usually describe as Google and Facebook
you mix them together you apply them to
the malware field so why Google because
we create this thing called vicetutor
intelligence which is like a search
engine over malware and you get to use
over 40 modifiers in order to identify
particular malware that interests you so
for instance you can do stuff like hey
let me know all that malware that
reaches out to Google Drive upon
execution or all that malware that is
detected by a given antivirus engine
with a given label and happens to be a
PDF that contains JavaScript so you can
combine more than 40 modifiers you know
25 particular families of malware that
interests you so that's the Google side
of things why do I say that similar to
Facebook similar to Facebook and that
for each match of your search results
you get to see a profile of every sample
in the data set so you get to understand
the individual items of malware and the
individual behavior thanks like to the
Sam boxing and virtual environment
execution that we do but you also get to
see the relationships with other items
in the data set so has this file being
downloaded from are given the URL or is
this file reaching out to giving domain
and what other files are reaching out to
those resources so it pulls in this
relationship notion that is similar to
the way that Facebook works you know but
applied to malware so we build this
intelligence tool over malware that many
security company security teams
worldwide views and it has its
counterpart as an epi the same
functionality but exposed
programmatically so that you can
integrate with your programs with the
core data set of not by your pseudo
built and that's like a very broad
overview of what we do is this something
we're doing in isolation or are we doing
this in conjunction with other security
researchers or anything like that yes so
the thing is the technology itself we
build it here and
virustotal but it's used by tons of
researchers worldwide so first first
people that use it as the antivirus
vendors participating by you still -
which are over 70 of them including
companies like Simon
Kaspersky McAfee etc you know and the
second set of users that would be using
it this as security teams and big
million companies so at the end of the
day they used the tool and generate
knowledge about malware that then
contributes to the worldwide defenses
against the bad guys so and in some way
we are an ecosystem where all the
security related individuals coexist and
work with each other sharing the
knowledge through virustotal
how did you how did the virus total idea
get off the ground to begin with so it's
a very interesting story like the
founder Bernardo way by early 2000 he
was doing antivirus comparatives so
performance comparatives of anti viruses
for a magazine and he had two needs one
he needed to compare this antivirus
solutions and doing it manually was
difficult so he wanted a way to automate
that task and secondly he needed samples
malware samples in order to test this
products okay so he hired a team that
went on to build the very first values
total and see since he had this mean
that he had already built this he said
hey why not expose it publicly because
I'm gonna receive malware samples I'm
gonna give value to other users that
might have a similar use case so these
days we don't promote that all antivirus
compare this with VT it's not something
you should be doing and but that's how
it was born and thereafter it's grown
into a tool that mostly any security
researcher in the world is using in
order to have a second opinion about
files and since we are receiving like
two million files per day well we get to
have a massive data set with all the
behaviors with all the related items and
this days it's more of like malware
change to that rather than its initial
use case when people submit stuff is
this an entirely automated process do we
have security researchers on outside
also doing stuff isn't it combined
what's that what's that back-end process
look like okay so what happens as either
they use the API or the public web
interface which under the hood uses the
API so you submit a file this reaches
certain Google cloud infrastructure
which happens to being in App Engine
appending is serving both the public
facing front end and it's also acting as
a back-end for the data store when the
file reaches appengine we copied to
Google storage and create attach to say
hey analyze this and this task goes into
pops up systems micro services that we
run at our end for instance one of them
is simply all the Avs
running in Google and compute engine so
we'll subscribe to this pub sub topic
get the V file scan it with all the anti
viruses send back the results either via
pops up or an HTTP POST in an internal
API to a pending and store it in the
datastore thereafter once we have all
this knowledge in the data set that's
when other researchers come over because
either they are checking hashes and
files against VT and they happen to
comment on those files and investigate
through the web interface or because
they have some kind of automation
pulling our feeds of malware etc so
that's the way it works and the end
output of this is that what the research
with VT they end up creating grows to
detect it and so this in some sense
nurtures the entire security industry
and we're making a dent on billions of
users through this security products
that happened to do their research with
VT all DAV Singh MVT security teams and
big companies that try to secure the
users at SATA
that's super cool I'm curious to know is
all like I've been just on the GCP side
of things why did you choose App Engine
where's that
really grateful for you how's that
working so if I rewind back in time for
the Google acquisition we actually run
our own data center in our office and it
was super noisy and you didn't wanna be
there you know what happened this we had
a couple of MySQL's and we have had a
couple of front ends in Apache and we
end up spending more time managing the
systems I'm doing administration rather
than coding I was horrible like every
single day we'll have some kind of MySQL
corruption that would lead to downtime
so once upon a time before the
acquisition Google came over and
actually offered us a deal to go on to
App Engine for free in exchange for
malware intelligence and that's how our
initial relationship got forged and we
started building opinion I wouldn't ever
return to the initial days right now we
can focus exclusively on coding rather
than on managing systems and for us it's
very seamless because it'll
automatically scales we don't have to
worry about scale it's the best decision
we ever made and probably we wouldn't
have being able to grow to the size that
we are today two billion files in the
collection without the Google
infrastructure we have like this
accounts for two petabytes worth worth
of data and Google storage you know and
that's only the files they realize
themselves then you have to count all
the metadata that we generate for them
is any of that data available for people
to do research on outside who are doing
research into security issues yeah
absolutely like we have several
offerings the ones that I mentioned
before are used to the intelligence on
our API they are licensed by third party
should not it's not only internal
research invite us to do on Google but
rather have you think about the biggest
companies on earth they probably are
always tulu customers so are all the
antivirus vendor and security companies
worldwide so they basically research
advanced persistent threats which are
like state-sponsored attacks against
their companies or they try to others
like mass malware which is targeting
their users stuff like yeah and
ends up in as I said before in in Drew's
to detect malware and we get to impact
like paintings refuses that way rather
than ask directly having billions of
uses as our users you know yes you
mentioned also something else
interesting and the process of things
getting processed you actually grab the
file on compute engine download it and
then apply the virus checkers and
various other automated systems
do you like isolate this file I mean
obviously this might be a file that may
contain malware so how do you make sure
that that doesn't spread to potentially
other parts of your system
when we run the Ailey's against the
files we don't really execute them it's
like a static analysis for the a/v stew
so in that sense there could be room for
infection if the a/v was exploited you
know but it's not like we are actively
infecting the machine but if we were
exploited the nice thing is that since
we would run this on compute engine we
have like a snapshot to which we can
revert which would be clean you know so
that allows us to go back really quickly
the second thing that we didn't do that
I mentioned is that we execute malware
in virtual environments so this we do in
for instance and stuff like VirtualBox
which is a virtualization layer and
thanks to the fact that recently we will
cloud introduced nested virtualization
we're able to run stuff like virtual box
inside compute engine also so that's the
way that it's isolated I didn't actually
know you could do that and now I need to
do that I need to run virtual focus on
GCE so it's actually really cool yeah we
have also a hybrid the infrastructure
because it's not something you could do
before but recently they did this
necessary choice agent stuff nice what
are some of the more interesting
experiences you've had with viruses or
more interesting viruses you've seen
that you have done things that were a
little out of the norm I would say
probably the most interesting thing I
can speak of that was discovered or
tracked down and completely understood
with virus to do list
so if you recall Stuxnet has been
attributed though not confirmed to be
some kind of malware that the Israeli
and US government did in order to slow
down the nuclear enrichment program of
Iran so basically it was a malware
targeting the nuclear stations in Iran
in order to slow down the centrifuge of
uranium in order to enrich uranium you
know so the cool thing about this is
that was actually discovered in 2010 and
the actual sample was MVT since 2007 so
for three years I was in VT and no one
really knew about it you know so when it
was discovered and I think it was people
from Symantec they were able to build
the entire picture just pulling
information from VT the initial dates
were when it was seen any other samples
that were related to that initial attack
and so on so that's probably one of the
most interesting ones oh but there's
tons like last year or the year before
that we had wanna cry that was a like
all over the press and the researcher
that and discovered the kill switch in
order to stop the propagation of that
worm was using VT for that yeah so it's
happening all the time another
interesting use case for VT is banking
Trojans so you have this strain of
trillions that try to target users of
electronic banking and others to steal
potentials and do automatic automated
transactions of money like wire
transfers to the account of either a
money meal already the end attacker and
teams within banks and other security
companies study these banking Trojans
all the time with VT in order to
understand for instance where is the
stolen data being sent to like which is
the command control for the malware so
that they can take down that command
control and all of a sudden they might
fix tons of infections worldwide
just by taking down the network
infrastructure of the Tholian simply i
also want to highlight I think that's
actually super interesting USR run
basically Lotus looks like a research
community like there's the virustotal
community you tell us a little bit more
about that yes so it's over six hundred
thousand researchers that sign up into
virustotal
there's several reasons why they sign up
one of them is because they want to vote
on the files and euros that they scan
with VT in order to for instance
highlight malicious stuff that's
undetected by the antivirus and security
industry today
so that way they can share this
information with the action malware
researchers to in detections another
reason for signing up is that they get
to get an API key to do some
programmatic work with the I used to
tell that I said and not only can they
vote on items and like I said they can
also place comments giving you the
entire background arguing file that they
uploaded so for instance they might be
on a given file that the uploading might
place a comment that has the actual spam
email from which the file came and then
this is really nice contextual
information for the antivirus and
security industry because not only they
get to see like the bullet but they also
get to see what the gun was and perhaps
even they get to understand who the guy
with the gun was you know so for many
the end goal is to actually understand
and know your enemy so the bullet is not
enough you have to see the entire
picture and actually the community helps
them in that sense where areas that
you'd like the community to provide more
help or more support or more insights is
right now we are actually doing a nice
effort and we have today the vertex of
Rav fires and we recently launched an
initiative which we call the multi
sandbox project so I mentioned that we
have our own like very tall setup where
we run samples right now we are
collaborating also with some partners
and new companies that want
to give us some boxing execution
behavior data for these samples that
that we have and that they see so that
not only we have the notion of what a
file does upon execution from the VT
point of view but also from other points
of view and this is really important
because often malware that's some kind
of cloaking whereby perhaps it won't
execute in Spain whereas it will execute
in China and so if we have partners all
over the world we get to see different
behaviors and we get cell fear against
malware that's trying to evade this
sample systems so that's something that
I would like to actually have more
violence working on right now we have
like I think four different companies
providing some books reports and we're
quickly growing this but I would like
more information in that sense how do
they get involved actually started off
at something called the anti-malware
testing standards organization in 2017
or 2018 I think so one of the AV
partners approached us and said hey we
not only want to be an AV like very
dicks kind of pioneer on V T we would
like to also provide our sandbox reports
why because our off-the-shelf solution
not only does like static detection but
also does behavioral detection and we
want users to know that we have
different layers built into our solution
and if like a malware evades the static
detection they might be gone and get
caught by a subsequent layer for
instance the behavior detection one so
the approaches and suggested this it
made a lot of sense for us so we get got
them on board and when we did that we
launched this initiative called multi
sandbox project in our blog we reached
out to our partners to tell them that we
were starting this and they're after
like it's being faisal israel even if
it's not known by my mom at home is very
known in the security industry so
it's just people emailing us and I'm
saying hey we do have our sound books at
up can we join so I double-checked our
website apparently we're clean
I checked I checked GCP podcast Macomb
and I just I just wanted to make sure
that's good to know
it's good to know yeah I'm sure it's
also now just made people go I wonder if
I should try to attack that are you
hiring so yes we are hiring so if you
know the story behind us okay we we when
independent company we would were
acquired by cool in 2012 we were
integrated in the Google security team
at one point it made sense for us to do
something bigger so we went on to Google
X in Google X there's been a much bigger
effort around security which now has
graduated from Google X into an
independent alphabet company called
Chronicle and Chronicle as a whole is
hiring Chronicle should be the alphabet
company that will address and do the big
moon shots in the security landscape so
it's really the place you wanna be at
and we are hiring both virustotal in
Malaga Spain but most importantly here
in the US in Chronicle you know
fantastic before we wrap up today is
there anything else you want to plug any
events you're gonna be at or anything we
haven't managed to cover in the podcast
make sure we get everything in we do
every so often like this data connector
same events we are gonna be in San Jose
on July 12 in rely in July 26 in besides
Las Vegas and that's an important one
because black hat which is the biggest
like hacker conference is happening at
that time we will be in August so
basically if you want to retell the meet
test just come by and perhaps and send
out an email to info at very subtle calm
we will be very happy to meet you at
blackhat so Emmy is there anything else
inside Google Cloud that you use I mean
you mentioned App Engine in GCE but
you've got lots of data what are you
doing there we're probably the guys that
use most DCP technologies from this from
the user base I won't bet on that but
for
sure we use a wide variety of tools so
for instance I mentioned that every
single compressed file that gets
uploaded to VT we decompress and
re-upload the inner contents and to VT
to see if there's anything malicious
there and to build the relationship
depends I'll delay ssin ship we do that
with a kubernetes engine as a micro
service that subscribes to the pops up
in topic that I mentioned before
so many of the of the micro services
that we run are actually on containers
in Google Cloud something else that we
do for instances we are really heavy
users of big cream we do it for two
things for any node through analytics so
we're a data set and we plug it into
stuff like Google Data studio and to do
nice charts and graphs and understand
how our users are using the platform but
also we even use it for advanced and
malware research in use cases so for
instance bigquery has a thing which
allows you to insert user-defined
functions which you write JavaScript and
it gets executed against every single
row that you have in bigquery
so any malware field there's this thing
called SS deep which is like a fuzzy
hash that allows you to understand
similarity between files so there's no
way you can search for similar files
over at 2 billion collection with
standard tools why because it means that
you have to convert this hash and do
computation against every other item in
the data set so that's 2 billion
compilers and you want quick results so
we have we plug this into bigquery and
like within seconds we know what are the
files similarly to a given sample that
interests you and this is done because
we have edit distance around that
running us you should define functions
in bigquery nice for instance since we
are users of the standard app
engineering environment but also of the
Flex environment whenever you have to
run for instance like stuff that won't
be only Python only or going on only so
we have containers deployed in Google
and
opinion flex and flex happens to not
have like this time that environment man
cash so we are also users of memory
store which is a a recent thing that was
announced and we're using like memcache
with memory store happening flex and we
are also users for instance of Google
Cloud SQL our main data set is actually
in the cloud data store but we have like
minor opinion services which run for
instance and WordPress for our learning
space and which is rights to TOCOM slash
learn so that our WordPress running and
Google opinion standard environment in
the PHP environment and that connects
and SQL which happens to be a group of
SQL so we're also eating as I said that
we are using appending section already
standard environment we do so when we
have I need to run certain code that's
not only python only oh : only and since
App Engine flex as a bit different to
the standard environment it doesn't have
like the memcache API so we needed
something like memcache so we are using
instead of that as the cloud memory
store offering that recently launched
which is built with Redis and that's
being super useful because before that
either we had to call out some kind of
internal API that we built in at the a
penance and environment now we no longer
have to do that we are also power users
of stuff like the I am administration
for our users or we need to make sure
that for instance an intern doesn't get
to deploy code to our main production
site and stuff like that so we manage
that with groups within the G suite
and because various tools are common
happens to be also a tea sweet account
so we have group set up there and then
those group have certain privileges and
will cloud dashboard so that's the way
that we manage our users and make sure
that no one should be doing what they
are not allowed to do that's a lot of
stuff you know it's like everything all
the things
oh and the one fun question I would ask
as well what languages do you write in
yes so
of our coders in Python we love Python
and it's very typical in the security
industry but we also have some opinion
services running with go and we go
environment and we also have like since
we have WordPress setup for a very small
use case that's on the PHP runtime great
fantastic
well Emmy thank you so much for hanging
out with us today it was super
interesting to hear about virustotal and
what you're all doing in the security
space thank you very much thank you so I
want to say thanks to Emmie Martinez for
joining us today from virustotal that
was a super interesting conversation
security research is really fascinating
definitely agree with you on that yeah
absolutely
ok well mark question the week question
the week this week's questions coming
from one of our listeners it is it's
coming from Andy Sheridan at Andy jsh he
asks what is the best practice for
multi-tenancy in Google cloud spanner
especially if customers are not the same
size and potentially have unequal load
right and so for this week's answer we
actually have one of our colleagues
Robert Kubus who is joining us to
basically answer yeah thanks for joining
us Robert because I have no idea how you
doing today Robert and hello everyone so
this is actually a really really good
question and to basically elaborate a
little bit on like how spanner works
behind the scenes so in Spain our data
is organized based on the primary key so
the primary key you choose that's how we
order the data and spanner and then we
split these data up in chunks and these
chunks responsibilities goes to the
spanner notes that you have in your
instance so now that means basically if
you have like a multi-tenant application
and you use a customer ID as an example
for primary key then all your data which
is belonging to one customer would go to
one node and basically as one node is
responsible for that and that can lead
to things like hot spotting so all your
load which is like all the data that is
loaded all the data that is read all the
queries that are going against this
customer basically have to be handled by
one node now you don't want that
especially in cases where you have
customers which are of unequal size
right so you have some large customers
and
a lot of small ones and a good way to
addressing this is to somehow you have
to basically split up your data in a way
that the irresponsibility can be given
to multiple nodes in your instance one
of the best practices that a lot of
people are doing there is basically
prefixing your primary key or using a
larger primary key in your tables so
prefix could be for something for the
example you could use some allah azza
element in your table and you hash that
element and you take that as a prefix in
your key and with that your data is
basically distributed among multiple
nodes and now if you have like very
large customers it gets distributed
between the available resources and it
doesn't matter if you have like a lot of
large or like a couple of large
customers and a couple of small ones
this is great robbery thank you so much
for joining us to help answer that
question and if anybody else out there
has more questions please feel free to
message us absolutely actually sir but
usually when we leave off where we talk
about where we're gonna be Robert where
are you are you doing any event soon are
you like talking about spender anywhere
if anyone wants to learn more about
spinner since we have you here yes sure
so the next big event that is coming up
for us is of course like next in San
Francisco I think F by now everybody's
speaking about it I will be there I have
two sessions and one is actually on
advanced topics on cloud spanner like
how to design your schemas to really get
the best out of cloud spanner so I can
talk about this I gonna talk a couple of
about metrics or how to do in cloud
spanner basically to the best of you
it's awesome that's great fantastic mark
where are you going to be so yeah I'm
just like Robert I'm gonna be at next
I'm gonna be speaking about a con is as
the open source project I've been
working on for running game servers I
think may be doing some other stuff but
yeah you and I are gonna be there
Melanie doing some podcast e stuff yes
we will and Melanie where are you gonna
be what are you up to I am going to be
speaking actually in the next couple
weeks at PyCon Russia oh cool yeah I
will be speaking about reinforcement
learning on the 22nd of July excellent
yeah but then I'll be at next wonderful
as well we all awesome
well Melanie rub it thank you very much
for joining us another weekly episode of
the podcast Thank You Marc thank you for
having me all right and thank you all
for listening
we'll see you all next week
[Music]
you